[Music]
all right let's go to
fayetteville arkansas we're going to
talk to another john
but with no h what's up john with no h
hey dr john i appreciate you taking the
time to listen to me a little bit man i
appreciate you brother
what's up how can i help you man well i
got i ended up getting
fired from my job in february and i
actually have a
i had a two-year contract so i'm getting
paid through march of next year
but i'm just struggling because i
thought i had another job in place i
haven't been able to find anything
and just trying to figure out where to
go from here
i mean they paid me good money there's
no financial need
it's just trying to find myself and find
a use because my
my job has always kind of been who i am
and i've struggled with that and pretty
self-aware of it but
yeah i'm just kind of having a hard time
with it sucks man
what'd you get fired for you know it was
actually because i was being
pursued and interviewed for other jobs
and didn't end up getting them but
thought there was a lack of loyalty and
went a different direction
was there a lack of loyalty you know i
i don't think so because the jobs i was
interviewing for were
uh promotions with 50 pay raise
big time programs that kind of thing so
i'm a man i i've had
seasons when i had hundreds of employees
okay
um anytime somebody worked for me had an
opportunity to go do something big
go get promoted go man i think i was
i always tried to be their number one
cheerleader man sure right
so i'll tell you this you're lucky that
you're out of this mess
okay if somebody would rather cut your
knees out and say how dare you try to
progress your career how dare you try to
go make more money how dare you
man you don't want to work there anyway
right right now that doesn't help
the existential issue which is you got
fired and that sucks
right there's some data that talks about
getting fired as like the psychological
impact which means the physiological and
biological impact
what does that mean you're not a wimp
that means that your body
has been injured okay similar to losing
a loved one
and when we lose a loved one we have a
whole process for that we have a funeral
we dress up in different clothes we talk
to our friends about it
we mourn it we have a drink we take some
time away
and when you get fired you just go try
to find another job
right right have you sat down and just
straight up
mourned this thing and grieved it you
know probably not
in that sense the first two months
afterwards i was
interviewing and looking for jobs and i
kind of
sat back and relaxed and said hey i'm
going to enjoy it i'm getting paid i've
got
two young kids at home i get to coach my
kids t-ball team for the first time but
i don't think i ever mourned it i've
tried to enjoy it and see the blessings
that i have in my life
but then after a couple days or a week
it goes back to the
embarrassment the shame there you go
that's it man so you ignored it you
tried to run from it and you hey
you ran from it towards good things man
coaching your kids t-ball team
being positive about it those are all
good things but you can't run from it
right okay what does the embarrassment
and shame come from
you know it's and i don't think she me
like my wife i feel like i've lost
respect and
she always comes in we talk about it
we've got a great relationship
but i'll say hey that was disrespectful
i know i don't have a job right now but
i'm still
trying and she said well i didn't mean
it that way and all my friends are in
the same
profession and they're super successful
and i i have been and been doing great
but it's and they're the best it just
when you're around them and they're
they're the again the best friends in
the world but
hey they're being successful they're
where i want to be and now all of a
sudden i'm not we're on the level
playing field now it's
hey i'm unemployed and can't get a job
when six months ago i was
turning turning down jobs that's right
that's right so you're in a season man
it's winter and it's cold outside right
yeah is it going to be this way forever
no and that's that's and that's the hard
part is because
march is a long way away but it's close
it's just
they're hiring it's kind of an
interesting career but
the hiring season is in the winter yeah
and kind of waiting for that to
come back again so here's what you need
my man
two things number one you need a purpose
you got to get out of bed every day
so i want you to go find just a job okay
go to a place where you can go do a
thing and it doesn't have to be your
dream job it doesn't have to be a
whatever but it's got to go be a thing
where you can contribute
and where you even if it's
i don't know if it's starbucks i don't
care what it is but you've got to go be
a part of something where you're
contributing
okay yeah and the second thing is is i
want you to double down on some service
i want you to find some people that are
not in your house that you can go serve
whether it's go
find two people on your street and just
mow the lawn and do that regularly
go find something outside of yourself
because right now you're stuck
inside your head and you are starting to
tell yourself stories about other people
who love you
and what happens is this thing's gonna
spin faster and faster and faster
on you they're not going to want to be
around you because you're going to be
hard to be around
and then it's going to spin faster and
spin faster and then it's going to
become a self-fulfilling prophecy
right yes so man
i've had buddies who've lost jobs i love
them
it's hard you know what i mean it's
heartbreaking right and
here we're going to make fun of them
either way because they're my friends
right so if they start working at
starbucks be like oh yeah
so that's part of it right i want you to
put your head
high you got fire dude own it
yeah right i think your wife still loves
you she still loves you
yep yeah dude she still loves you that's
awesome and
does uh your kids still love you
absolutely yeah man
and so have a funeral for this thing
probably take your wife out and let's do
this thing right
let's have a funeral for it i want you
to be open about like
i feel like a failure i feel like a
loser and i'm gonna put these feelings
to bed today i'm gonna acknowledge i
liked this job i wish i hadn't gotten
fired from it
um i was a good employee and they let me
go
and and then we're gonna have a
proper funeral for this thing and then
you're gonna get up and you're gonna go
find a job
and dude if somebody won't hire you
because you had interim work
then you don't want to work there either
i would love for somebody to have a
paycheck for a year and they're like man
i just went and ground one out
i just went over there to starbucks i
went over there to my neighbor's firm i
went to work for one of my buddies
doing three levels below what i normally
do just to have a
have a job to contribute get up and um
shower and put my clothes on for
whatever
um but dude go towards that okay and
make sure you're modeling for your kids
make sure you're modeling hey man every
single one of us gets punched in the
mouth
hard here's what getting up looks like
here's what grieving it looks like
here's what being sad looks like
here's what gratitude looks like here's
what service looks like
and if you can't if kids are old enough
to drag them along and make them all the
yards with you
right just go for a walk in the evening
and pick up trash in your neighborhood
do it for an hour who cares
you're doing something to contribute
okay and it gets getting you out of your
head
here's the thing my brother you're not a
loser you're not yeah you got fired
sucks hate it hate it hate it hate it
but you're not a loser
no that's and that's i i know that and
again i said i'm pretty self-aware but
it kind of resonates because
i had another great job before and it's
a different profession but
ended up getting hurt and couldn't do it
anymore i went down kind of that
that path and i could feel my mental
health going down i'm not there because
it was
it was different it was right after
college it was i mean it was
playing professional football and now
it's
you know and obviously you know about
that transitioning from
a professional athlete to something else
is hard and i kind of got through it
got back to the top of another career
and i just feel myself going down that
path again hey what do you want to do
man
i'm a football coach that's what i do
it's and i i know i need to
not live in my career but that's that's
my purpose
you love coaching what ages college
you love coaching college ball right oh
yeah college ball is a zoo right now
right it's a bananas
could you call a local high school and
say hey i want to help out in spring
ball
and and i've i've gone down that path
it's just i don't want to commit to
something and then if a job comes up
hey not do it you're going to do that
you're going to oh
you know you know yourself until you're
not going to get out of bed
you're right right so i want you to be
on the phone with a high school or a
middle school this week
okay and go let them know hey dude i got
canned from whatever university
and um i'm a good coach i'm searching
the country for it
and by the way when you're in when
you're a football coach you move a lot
and you also got a wife who's hanging on
now
that's right who can't commit to a
community or to a church or to her
friends because she's going to pack up a
move
and they live in that limbo i worked it
in university administration my wife
experienced the same thing and i didn't
realize it
that she was afraid the joke in our
house but it wasn't a joke was
planting asparagus she loves having a
big garden but those take two or three
years to come up
and she'd say i can't ever plant
asparagus because i never know we're
gonna live
and that broke my heart right and so
this year was the first year she
actually planted it since we've been
married
right so all to say is man go down there
and just start finding yourself get your
whistle out and get those
weird ridiculous coaching shorts out and
and go get involved in the lives of
young people get back out there
and the calls will come man you know
that
yeah hoping so stop
maybe you'll maybe you'll find out you
love coaching high school ball
i coached high school it's awesome
probably not but
dude you got to go do you know this
right yeah
yeah do i have your word you're going to
go make some calls today
yes sir excellent excellent man
and get out there and go volunteer help
out with them whether it's in the weight
room whether that's whatever
go make it happen and then dude get on
the phone and start calling some folks
i know that especially the college
coaching world man
it is about your friends and who you
know and your brothers and your sisters
and go make that stuff happen
right and if you've ever
thought about transitioning out of
coaching into doing something else or
transitioning to high school instead of
college
now is the time what do you
want to do college coaching is going to
look super different in the next few
years
especially if ut and ou blow up the big
12 and then the domino
oh it's going to be a mess it's going to
be awesome but it's going to be a mess
and they can pay players the whole
landscape is shifting if you've ever
thought
man maybe uh now's that time
right but you gotta get it gotta get out
of your head
go serve go be with go do
right go go do but i want you to first
have a funeral with your wife
more in this job let this thing exhale
tell her you're sorry for
taking her all over the country and now
she's just in that limbo land
and then get after it hey man thanks for
the call dude i'm grateful that you
trusted me with that
don't on we talk he got fired he got
fired i got fired
dude that's the loss of a loved one it
hurts and it hurts
bad all right man thank john thank you
so much for that call dude you're
awesome
go do you got it you got it